أليكس إذا نظرت إلى الرسم البياني الخاص بي فلن تتمكن من
رؤيته ولكن أعني أن هناك خطوطًا في
كل مكان وهذا في الأساس
معقد بشكل لا يصدق، ومن الأمثلة الجيدة على ذلك ما
حدث بالأمس من هذا الانعكاس في
تركيا ويبدو أنه أدى إلى
حل هذه المشكلة مع الاتحاد الأوروبي
لا  ريتشارد في الواقع أعتقد أن
الوضع بسيط للغاية وهذا قد
يبسط الأمر بالنسبة لك، فنحن ننظر إلى
أوروبا مقسمة بشكل دائم إلى حد ما مع وجود
جانبين على جانب واحد لديك
روسيا معزولة وعلى الجانب الآخر
لديك أكثر أو أقل من 40
دولة أوروبية  البعض في حلف شمال الأطلسي، والبعض في الاتحاد الأوروبي، والبعض الآخر لا
يطمح إلى كل من
الحالة النهائية والحالة الأساسية هنا
بسيط للغاية، حيث سترى أوكرانيا
في كل من الاتحاد الأوروبي وفي حلف شمال الأطلسي
على المدى الطويل، وسترى أيضًا
دولًا مثل  بدأت جورجيا ومولدوفا
في الاقتراب على الأقل من
الاتحاد الأوروبي بما في ذلك منطقة البلقان، لذا فإن
كل ما لم يرغب بوتين في
حدوثه هو في الأساس أعتقد أنه
عالم منقسم إلى قسمين بكل بساطة.